Well, let's think acceleration is zero which means force is up, must be balanced by forces down.
What are the forces up, well these two combined.
Our force down is just mg and we're looking for Fns and check it out.
The normal force provided by the scale which is how hard the scale is pushing up on you,
is equal to the weight mg minus the normal force from the ground,
and that's how hard the ground is pushing up.
Since, I'm subtracting something from mg, this gets smaller.
Now it turns out in this first situation, the scale would have accurately measured your weight.
If you weigh 70 kg, the scale would have read 70 kg because FN was equal to mg.
In this case, the scale would have read less than 70 kg.
So, what the scale is actually measuring is not your weight.
They're measuring how hard they have to push up, so that you don't fall through. Pretty cool.